hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about the seven ways to have a
true impact as an entrepreneur so a
theme that comes up a lot is that if you
want to have success as an entrepreneur
the money can't be the most important
thing that you're going after money yes
is important but it can't be the number
one if you look the most successful
people who've made a lot of money money
maybe two or three on the list but
number one there's something that's more
important than money and it's having
that big impact and so today I'm going
to talk about the seven ways I have a
true impact as an entrepreneur number
one is you need to find your one word I
know I wrote a book about it I know it
sounds a little bit self-serving but
it's true you have to find the thing
that drives you you have to have the
self-awareness to know what it is that
you stand for what is the impact that
you wanna have that's what it's all
about you can't just say you want to
have an impact but then not have a plan
right you need to know what the impact
is that you want to have so for me I
want to spread more belief I want people
to believe in themselves I want people
to believe in the work that they're
doing I want people to believe that it's
going to work out and to keep on
hustling and keep on trying keep on
adding that perseverance you need to
know what you stand for you need to know
what your one word is so that you can go
out and create an amazing impact that
has clarity and focus and purpose too
many people want to have a big impact
but they'd have no idea what that big
impact looks like and so you're never
going to get there so you need to find
your one word you need to understand
what your main core value is and what
that impact actually looks like
[Music]
number two is identify your niche once
you know what your one where it is once
you know the value that you're trying to
create out there in the world and spread
more of you have to figure out where
you're going to attack what's the knee
[ __ ] you're going to attack so for me
it's entrepreneurs if you want to be the
world's greatest saxophonist I can
believe in you as much as I want to
write and that can help you there'll be
some value out there right having a
little injection of belief is definitely
valuable but I don't know anything about
being a saxophone player right i can't
give you specific knowledge I don't have
the contacts to be able to help you if
you want to be in on twitter i know that
i've done that i am that I live that I
breathe that I believe that I do that
every day and so finding the niche helps
me have a greater impact right so just
saying believe is great and I can help
people believe in themselves it's great
but I can have way more power and way
more impact in a way greater leverage on
people when I know what I'm talking
about and so I can do that in the world
of entrepreneurship I could do that in
the world of salsa I can kind of do that
in the world of League of Legends to
some extent a little bit in the world of
baseball right in some worlds but
entrepreneurship is where I rain and so
you need to understand what your niche
is as well what is the audience that you
want to impact with your message find
your niche
[Music]
number three is set a big goal you have
a big impact what does that look like
again the more specific you can be the
easier it's going to be to motivate you
to want to go and do it right if I say I
want to help a thousand entrepreneurs
that may not be the most motivating of
goals right I'm not going to crime out a
bad to say yes my life's purpose is to
help a thousand entrepreneurs now if I
was helping them one on one if I wanted
to invest in a thousand businesses and
help those companies really take off
then maybe maybe that is male to make a
thousand angel investments that's no
joke that's a big deal but my goal I
want to help a billion entrepreneurs I
want to have a big reach I want to make
a big mark I want to have a big impact
on this world when I leave it right it's
not going to happen I'm not hitting a
billion people tomorrow but I'm
motivated by that I'm driven by that I
want to go out and accomplish I want to
do big things with my message and
abilities to be able to help people and
so having a big goal that you look at
that sometimes it's scary sometimes you
look at and say I don't know if I can do
that those goals are important much more
than having goals that are so low that
you know you can hit that don't really
drive you forward Les Brown was always
famous they're saying that most people
don't set goals that are too big and
miss they set goals that are too low and
they hit and then you're complacent and
you don't drive for more right so having
a big goal that gets you excited and
scared and self-doubt sometimes but
motivated is important to really have a
big impact
[Music]
number four is then create a plan right
great to have a goal just like having
your one word it's great it's great to
have that now you need to put the plan
in place for how you're going to go and
accomplish it so you want to go help a
billion people you want to go make a
thousand angel investments whatever that
goal looks like for you what's your plan
to then go out and create it and you may
not have the perfect plan and don't
worry so much about creating the perfect
plan a lot of people get held up here
and that they work so hard on making the
perfect plan they never do anything
about it but you need to have some kind
of plan you need to study success you
need to put an action what you think is
going to work what logically makes sense
but you need to start making the plan to
go and achieve that big goal that you
set yourself number five is take
consistent action this is where a lot of
people fall down a lot of people have
big dreams big goals but they're not
consistent they take a little bit of
action maybe a lot of action then they
lose their motivation they don't do
anything for a week or a couple days and
there's more action and then nothing and
it's just constant start and stop and
start and stop and you never get
anywhere right in that car that is just
always on the brakes you need consistent
action every single day at least 30 to
60 minutes ideally more but at least 30
to 60 minutes every single day on
building your idea on building your
business on reaching for that big impact
that you are chasing it's important you
know what my youtube channel started
taking off when i started doing daily
content i used to be the guy was like oh
once a week thats so much to make one
video a week is crazy it's so much time
so much effort to be so much easier to
do when a month and it's not until you
make it a priority we are doing it
consistently it's for any goal as such
as the business thing you want to lose
weight you need to work out consistently
you need to eat healthy consistently
right you need to have the plan that's
important but you need to stick to the
plane you got to do something about it
and not just work out a little bit and
then stop and eat healthy for a while
and then eat a bunch of crap you're
going to be constantly
be doing this I never actually making
the growth you want to have a great
relationship it's being consistently a
good husband a good wife a good
boyfriend a good girlfriend a good
father a good mother right it's not oh
it's your birthday I'm going to get you
flowers or once a month I'm going to be
nice to you it's consistent you want to
have success in any field you need to
take consistent action and that's one of
the things we're a lot of entrepreneurs
fall down you have great ideas you've
great ambition you've great vision
you're just not consistent you don't do
the work every single day number six is
built a team this is really important
because you need to understand that to
do big things you can't do it alone it's
so easy to want to be the lone wolf
entrepreneur to feel like you can do
everything better than anybody else and
people that you've hired before hasn't
worked out and so you're going to shrink
back down and do it all yourself again
that's what a lot of people do right
like I'm going to grow okay great i'm
going to build a team i hire somebody
and that person doesn't work out and so
you think I'm never going to hire
anybody because that first one didn't
work out so I'm never gonna hire anybody
again and I'm just gonna do it all
myself right well you know did your
first relationship work out or some
people yes but most people know you
probably sucked as a manager you
probably hired the wrong person to begin
with because it's not just about hiring
for skills you need to hire for values
you probably didn't give them enough
time to train them and motivate them and
encourage them and understand who they
are as a person they may have sucked but
you probably equally sucked as a boss
you learn through your relationships you
learn through the hires you have you
learn to the business that you create
and so you need to build a team if you
want to do something big this video's
about having a big impact you cannot do
it by yourself you need to build the
team you need to focus on what is it
that you can bring genius level talent
to what are you among the best people in
the world at and how can you spend as
much time doing that as possible and
have the people on your team doing
everything else now you don't just start
day one with a thousand people on your
team I get it you may be starting by
yourself that's fine but look for as
soon as possible to bring people
whether it's an intern I started with
interns I had high school interns I had
foreign language interns who wanted to
learn English and came to Canada and
work for me for free for three to 12
months I had high school interns were
getting a credit for their class and
worked for me for a school year right
hey nothing I had people on part-time
gigs the first person i hire was part
time one hour a day to help free up my
time so you don't have to jump the
hiring sell me for 50k starting salary
full-time there are ways to get
volunteers to get partners to get people
to help you out to get interns you want
to always be keeping your ears open for
potential talent and start building your
team as soon as possible a number seven
is former great environment I talked
about this a lot on on my videos it's
probably going to be a future book of
mine at some point most people's
environment just socked your environment
keeps you where you are we've talked
about it how many times in his videos
have to change your environment have you
done it yet is it sinking in yet what is
on your wall at your office where you
are working I don't care what's in your
basement I don't care if it's at your
mom's house I don't care if you have an
actual office what is on the wall are
you inspired going there to work every
day what is your morning routine do you
do something every day to get your
mindset right to go out and believe in
that big thing you have this video is
about helping you have a big impact if
your mind is not set properly if you
don't wake up every day thinking that
you can have a big impact if you don't
wake up every day motivated to want to
go and have a big impact guess what's
going to happen you're not gonna have a
big impact because that one afternoon
when you feel motivated and courage it's
not enough it's not sustainable so think
about the times we've been most
motivated most inspired most dreaming
big what happened who are you talking to
what were you consuming what were you
listening to what were you watching what
was it what happened in your life and
now inject that with purpose every
morning into your routine so that you
automatically every
a wake up and you get motivation and you
believe in that bigger impact that you
can have it's so important guys and I've
talked about it over and over and over
again and I don't see the action
happened and so I really want you to
think about what's on your walls what
your morning routine looks like what
your habits are and make some changes so
that you can start having the big impact
that you can actually have so that's
what I got guys those are my seven ways
that you can have a big impact as an
entrepreneur I love to know what did you
think what way was your favorite what
way did you agree with the most
resonated most with did I miss something
is there an eight nine ten that you guys
want to add to the list leave it down
the comments below I'm going to join in
the discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Luca of an ally Luca
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon